and rotate
the most Googled man in the world at one
point
has finally been charged in Romania
with rape human trafficking and forming
an organized crime group to sexually
exploit women who is Andrew Tate Andrew
Tate is a self-help Guru social media
influencer guy he's very very talented
at going viral on the internet
I he has a lot of Defenders
especially among young people on the
right especially and you know he's not
like sitting at home reading his Edmund
Burke in a bow tie this is a guy who's
very Brash he makes comments that are
often very offensive some of them are
kind of bizarre like he defended
he said that he would rather
sleep with a trans like a man
who looks really good then a
old really old he said what was that I
want to get the Align exactly right he
said I would rather sleep with a trans
woman who looks like Megan Fox than a
an actual woman who looks like Hulk
Hogan or something to that effect and so
he's just really good at going viral and
now he's been charged with all these
crimes and a lot of people are are
defending him
and I think I am both much less and more
inclined to defend this guy than a lot
of people because a lot of Andrew Tate's
Defenders don't want to admit that
the guy is a pimp and Pimpin though it
ain't easy also ain't good this is one
of the videos that would seem to
incriminate Andrew Tate in some of this
weird sex stuff
so the recruitment process is the same
as the PHD course
you message them on Instagram the PHD
course is my recruitment system I don't
mention webcam
until after I've had sex with the girl
you continue as normal no mention of
webcam you girl after a girl you do the
PHD test
if she passes the PHD test and she wants
to be with you
then you start mentioning things like
yeah but you know you're always busy
you're always at work you can come work
for me so you don't want girls in it for
money you want girl who's in it to be
with you so you meet a girl you take on
dates or whatever she passes the PHD
test then you start saying things like
oh yeah but you're always working I have
to do some traveling and you can't come
I want to bring you with me traveling is
a great one because the things about
this business is mobile if you can find
good Airbnb with good internet you can
run it somewhere else so it's a good
little caveat to throw in uh you're
always working why don't you work for me
so we spend more time together
it's a pretty dark stuff
he's he's here this is on
pickupartistools.com which is not in the
bookmarks of my web browser but you
might say well maybe he's just talking a
big game except he actually did have a
business where he was pimping out these
girls on online and what he's saying
here is so dark because he's saying
if you just offer the girl money it's a
consensual transaction so it's not rape
if you just offer the girl money she's
going to leave you once you make some
money but if you seduce the girl and and
you deceive her into thinking that you
love her and you want to seriously date
her or marry her or something like that
then she's more likely to stick with you
and make you more money so that's what
you've got to do and that's really
really dark right now go to
goodranchors.com use promo code Knowles
as our great nation's birthday
approaches we are coming together as
proud Americans and savoring the
delicious Taste of homegrown American
made meet our friends of good Ranchers
have the best Quality Meats you've ever
tasted and they only sell meat that was
raised here in the USA from now until
Independence Day good ranchers will be
offering the best deals to give you
freedom from the meat aisle from Ribeyes
New York strips all natural Burgers to
the most delicious chicken you could
ever want good ranchers has something
for everyone plus right now you will get
30 off with our code Knolls
goodranchers.com this is the way to wow
your family the Fourth of July
I am very Discerning about my meat I eat
a lot of red meat and these guys they're
just the best in the business they've
got the best quality they've got by far
the best prices they're just great guys
with a great company It's All American
made so what are you waiting for
let the mouth-watering aroma of American
made me fill the air bringing Joy unity
and delectable flavors to your
celebrations goodranchers.com use code
Knolls get 30 bucks off any box promo
code notes goodranchers.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
right now go to carzang.com Knowles
buying a new car
it can be a stressful experience for
everyone
that's especially true if you're a first
time buyer if you've got no credit
before you walk into that dealership
before you spend the entire day with the
crowds and the stress and the potential
to not even find the right car
you got to check out karzing carsing is
completely changing the way you buy a
car online by partnering with Credit
Agencies and lenders and over 25 000
dealers Nationwide carsing provides you
with everything you need before stepping
foot into a dealership once you find the
right car at your ideal budget all you
got to do is bring your saved deal
voucher with you to the dealership to
finalize your next ride it is super
simple even if you're not in the market
for a new car you should check out
karzing anyway karzing's online window
shopping experience goes beyond mirror
images you can dive deep into each
vehicle's specs features and performance
capabilities zoom in on craftsmanship of
the Interior Marvel at The Cutting Edge
technology admire the meticulous
attention to detail that sets these cars
apart from the rest carzing helps make
your experience faster cheaper and less
stressful go to carson.com Knowles get
the best deals near you carzing.com
slash Knowles back in ancient Greece
seduction was treated as worse than rape
and we don't we don't think of that that
now we think of Seduction as totally
fine and kind of funny but seduction is
really really bad the argument among
those old ancient Greeks was that rape
violates the body obviously very very
bad but seduction violates also the soul
that that for that reason it it takes on
an even darker aspect and so this is all
really really
really bad stuff and I'm not inclined to
defend anybody who says this stuff and
much much less does this stuff as as
some kind of conservative hero or
something like that the very fact that
the guy was in Romania raises a lot of
questions because Romania is kind of a
dodgy place so you gotta ask like well
why would someone willingly go to
Romania okay now all of that said
all of that said
does everyone really think that this
indictment is a arrest and and later
indictment I guess is on the up and up
I don't think so they're clearly going
after this guy's money the charges
clearly seemed trumped up and then if
you want to go after this guy for
pimping women which I think is perfectly
fine in principle I gotta ask why aren't
you going after pharaohs and tune Farrah
santune is one of the founders and
former CEO of Mind geek which is the
biggest porn company in the world
why aren't you going after that that
guy's doing the same thing at a much
larger scale than Andrew Tate is why
aren't you going after Scott montgomer
he's the current guy running mind keep
why don't you go after what is her name
uh I'm Rob I'm rappally gone who's the
CEO of only fans all of these people are
pimping out women at a much larger scale
than Andrew Tate ever has why aren't
those guys getting arrested why aren't
those guys having their money stolen why
aren't those guys being held for months
without charges
you you don't need to defend Andrew Tate
or his view of the world and maybe he's
turned it around I think I read
somewhere that he converted to Islam
which is which is another conversation
we could have I guess so you don't need
to really defend Andrew Tate to point
out
a fact that we have observed
increasingly in the United States which
is that the law is not being applied
fairly here it's not being applied
evenly it's just being applied to attack
people who in any way criticize the
regime you could be Bobby freaking
Kennedy you could be a Kennedy Democrat
royalty but if you if any you can remain
a committed liberal but if you if you
question the regime on certain
instruments of its power and maybe you
go up against the guy who's at least
ostensibly running the regime they're
going to go after you they're going to
censor you you can pimp out women which
is now a fetid Hobby and Industry among
the liberal establishment but if you do
so and then use your platform to
criticize that same establishment oh
they're going to take all your money
they're going to rush you they're going
to throw you in prison why are we going
after these relatively low level guys I
mean Andrew rotate is prominent enough
why are we going after guys who've
committed crimes in a relatively modest
way when we let the guys who commit
those very same crimes in a much more
egregious way
whether we're talking about classified
documents Hillary Clinton Joe Biden much
more egregious than whatever Trump did
Bill Clinton for that matter
why are we letting the people who commit
the real serious massive crimes off
the hook because it's a political
prosecution boy wasn't that a great clip
make sure you subscribe here ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael Knowles
show channel before we're nuked from
orbit see you next time